[Música]
yo soy yo soy flor amargo mucho gusto
estoy muy contenta de estar aquí por
primera vez en playa miramar en
la conferencia ted porque luego lo
pronunció mayor bueno yo
la verdad es que estoy muy nerviosa
porque es la primera vez que voy a
hablar de mí así abiertamente de cómo
empecé sin entrevista y sin alguien que
me esté preguntando o sea yo tengo que
decirlo todo
él
yo creo mucho y mi concepto es la
espontaneidad yo de niña me acuerdo que
mi abuelo me ponía discos de música y yo
bailaba con las sillas mientras él me
estaba viendo yo estaba bailando con las
sillas y giraba y todo
y yo jamás pensé que yo iba a ser músico
hasta que había un director de orquesta
porque yo como fernando platas yo nadaba
pero en la cama en las cobijas yo jugaba
que nada y una vez saliendo así dominado
vio una pantalla y vio un director de
orquesta y dije no manches está
dirigiendo a la orquesta yo me quedé
pasmada elige yo tenía cuatro años y
dije mamá yo quiero hacer eso
y me aman y me pelo estaba así como fija
entonces yo pues yo soy en mi curso y a
los 7 a los 6 años mi mamá hagan de
cuenta que yo iba en la escuela yo era
el ser que no hablaba en el ser que ya
saben super callada nunca decían nada
hasta pensaban que tenía autismo me
acuerdo que iba al dentista me estaba
doliendo y yo o sea no hacía ninguna
expresión
yo vi a mi mamá me dice que crees hija
que van a traer un piano
y yo o sea ya nada más había visto los
pianitos piano saurios y yo dije no
manches o sea yo no dije no manches pero
ahorita lo digo
y entonces este no entonces me dijo mamá
reza para que llegue bien el piano a la
casa y yo sí y siempre hacíamos
oraciones en la mañana no esté la
oración empezaba con armonía para todo
el mundo de acuerdo a la voluntad divina
bajo la gracia de manera perfecta y el
nombre de mi poder superior de mi poder
divino y yo te pedimos que el piano
llegue bien que llegue con todas las
teclas
y entonces me acuerdo que voy llegando a
mi casa o saliendo a la escuela además
en la escuela me acuerdo que había
tenido un mal día porque la maestra me
dejó así toda la clase porque se me
había olvidado el libro de ciencias
naturales de la jirafa entonces hagan de
cuenta que cuando dijo a quién se le
olvidó levante la mano y te quedas así
toda la clase no
entonces yo iba así de no ya está muy
mal todo y de esas veces que yo iba
súper triste como ya saben en la escuela
casi nadie me hablaba y era muy rara
para todos
luego ya les cuento porque llegó a la
casa
y ve a lo lejos así
puedo ver así un piano dije no manches
sólo lo veía no sabía que era no sabía
cómo sonaba pero cuando lo vi ni
siquiera me atrevía a tocarlo la primera
canción que aprendí a tocar fue ésta
y yo
cada quieto nada eso yo sé que es muy
sencillo
[Música]
la
pero para mí era
hola
[Música]
para mí era eso era la oportunidad que
yo tenía para sacar todo eso que no
podía decir todo eso que me callaba
incluso cuando me estaban sacando eso en
los dientes cuando llegaba a mi mamá del
trabajo
cuando no le podía me podía acercar a
nadie porque todos me decían que estaba
mal ser como yo era
cuando no podía decir lo que era esperar
a mi madre a que llegara y esperarla con
un tecladito mil meses la misma canción
y la música me acompañaba todo ese
momento en que mi madre no estaba yo no
sabía que ya había una magia
acompañándome a pesar de la soledad que
estaba viviendo y cuando llegó ese piano
pude expresar yo no quería clases de
piano obvio yo quería jugar fútbol
pero yo quería seguir que el piano vive
italia ni sabía previamente ya saben
fueras notitas que ahorita no sanaron es
así y mi mamá no tienes que aprender o
viendo el piano
y yo no luego ya me confesó que era una
broma pero no saben cómo sufría pero el
vídeo quería aprender pero al mismo
tiempo quería jugar el fútbol entonces
me acuerdo que un y modo me metieron una
academia y dije chin no voy a tener que
aprender y en la academia
empecé enamorarme de este instrumento
empecé primero con ella saben cómo sin
conocer yo tenía ocho años y me dicen
vamos a ir a un concurso y me acuerdo
que a los ocho años no lo recuerdo muy
pero empecé así
[Risas]
[Música]
y sin manchas dije guau sea mi estado
puesto entonces después de un tiempo
jamás me imaginé
que la música iba a trascender en mí
tanto me enamoré de la música me m o se
hagan de cuenta que
yo cuando estaba tocando cuando estaba
en dentro de mis canciones favoritas
bueno yo me iba en micro a los mercados
lejanos a conseguir un cassette por una
canción
observa como por la música no manches
y cuando tomé la decisión de después de
las clases y que vieron que tenía
talento y que muy bien y que las
reuniones familiares para tocar maiden
tocalli ja yo
min
entonces después de eso que pasó de ser
pues imagínense nadie me pelaba y de
pronto ya todo el mundo no manches que
bien tocas que tal entonces todo yo ya
no te amo más y dije no manches el piano
me hace por primera vez me hace que me
vean así de aquí estoy y empecé a buscar
en la música algo que no debía de buscar
en ella sino dentro de mí y sufrí porque
yo por primera vez había sido abrazada
por primera vez había sido valorada por
primera vez alguien me decía qué bonito
tocas en la escuela cuando me hacían
bullying donde hay una guitarra donde
hay un piano donde hay una para que para
decirles por medio de la música algo
mira como toco no me digas así
no te burles en mí
y así fue mi camino y muy joven empecé
erróneamente a buscar eso que tenía
enterrado esas ganas de ser queridas que
todos tenemos
hacia arriba
me acuerdo que tenían la mente voy a
formar mi banda de músicos me fui al
conservatorio y estaba tan arraigada la
idea porque mi herida era tan grande que
yo dije yo tengo que encontrar músicos
me fui al conservatorio pegué letreros
por todo cuéllar cada poste tenía un
letrero se busca baterista se busca
baterista todos me tardaba días en poner
letreros quería mi banda ya tenía ese
deseo
y en eso tengo mi banda se deshace
porque yo no pensaba yo estaba guiada
por algo que no estaba dentro de mí no
estaba consciente y en eso ya tengo mi
banda
y para no hacerles el cuento largo me
dice cómo se va a llamar
no importa yo quiero tocar yo quiero
tocar me acuerdo que estamos ensayando
en una estética y yo tenía tantas ganas
esta fue mi primera canción la soñé
[Música]
y entonces mi amigo que era guitarrista
dijo los machos está bien si lo vamos a
meterle la cocal y se darán cuenta era
un juego yo no sabía que me iba a
dedicar ni que iba a ganar dinero joan
mamá yo era un amor y entonces me
acuerdo que entramos a un concurso y le
dicen cómo se vayan a la banda chocolate
amargo
y yo dije oh sí
no importa cómo nos llamemos chocolate
amargo pero ya había un chocolate
abuelita registrado
entonces la hermana de vicente se le
ocurrió
flor en flor es como un sinónimo bueno
la flor amargo y con ustedes flor amargo
y yo con una banda y una nana
yo con una falda de tul negra en versión
darks que me acuerdo que cantaba
demencia
pero la
de superar
les dijo en el rollo de querer que me
vieran hace un tiempo
perseguida y cegada equivocadamente de
lo que quería in anhelaba de la música
había quedado muy atrás la niña que
amaba realmente la música y se había
convertido en una guerra conmigo misma
de lo voy a lograr lo voy a lograr y
atrás las las voces de mi papá no te voy
a apoyar
hasta aquí se acabó mi apoyo y si sigues
con el piano
olvídate de mí
pasos por la puerta
me quedé sentada en la silla del piano
yo había estado pensando en una canción
instantáneamente como si hubiera sido un
suspiro de mi dolor porque ni yo misma
sabía lo que estaba pasando
cante
an
qué
me quiere ayudar
bien
para entender
y me quiero
[Música]
sacar de aquí
ah
y allí me di toda mi fuerza todo lo que
sé
[Música]
se trabajaba quiero encontrar
y que por una desnuda el alma a plena
luz
descriptor
[Música]
y adoro a su voz
ah
y ese fue
[Aplausos]
mi contestación al dolor
y dije
no importa sin dinero tengo que hacerlo
creo en mí me gusta lo que hago lo tengo
que hacer yo no sabía pero yo decía yo
voy yo pollo pollo yo sí siempre ha sido
mi apellido es carvalho
soy un caballo yo
para terminar
después de esta canción pasaron muchos
años
me dan me firmaron en una disquera en
una de las más importantes
wow
ya la s
y alfombra roja premios oye yo llego
flor embargo pero en realidad había una
mujer que como no sabía no estaba no
conocía dentro de mí que había detrás de
la música yo iba a sí pero por fuera
ya sabes
y dije
eso terminó me dieron mi carta de retiro
pues el primer programa de la voz mexico
no figure
y yo cuando no habían escenarios para mí
yo ya dije ya me voy a hablar de la
música voy a dar clases y empecé a
enfermarme
de estómago todo el tiempo estaba
enferma y todo mi sueldo era para
gastroenterólogos todo
y un día veo unos músicos en la calle
no estaban tocando árabe mi favorito y
yo dije no no en reforma y la gente y el
calor de raineri
en un saxofón yo no dije no ya de aquí
soy y entonces con mis últimos ahorros
así de que me corrieron además porque o
sea ya no había trabajo para mí en ese
lugar donde trabajaba ya que mi dinero
me compré mi voz y me está recargable y
a la calle y todos me decían hoy no pues
ya me acompañaban como para no dejarme y
al principio fue como de como que todos
estaban así en la calle hacia el lado de
un burger king así
y yo
como que estábamos de menor ya mira a
los cinco meses
y pasaban los taxis y yo
[Música]
con todo y entonces cierran la calle yo
dije no ya ya estoy salada y me
encuentro a la del metro a vanessa la de
cultura digo por favor déjame tocar en
las estaciones te lo pido por favor
déjame hacer una yo te amo lo que hago
por favor en el medio estaba enamorada
de la calle yo limpiaba mi espacio como
bendito en una cola de vita pero desde
ahora de muchachos a todos arreglar bien
nuestro pedacito lloran feliz
y gracias a que me abrieron las puertas
del metro
logré el primer vídeo viral que fue la
loca pianista del metro
de mi importados los nombres flor amargo
lo único que quería era tocar
la nuca pianista del metro
y el día de hoy para mí
la música
eso que tanto a mí me ha llevado a
conocer
la felicidad más bella
la conciencia
la conciencia de saber que existe algo
más que esta dimensión
existe la magia la magia cuando te
atreves a ser auténtico cuando te
atreves a esta parte y decir esto soy y
los pequeños detalles esos escenarios
donde nadie quería ir
yo son mis favoritos son mi escuela
y compuse esta última canción en un
momento muy difícil de mi vida que dice
así que es mi aliento además
la vida enseñando que sólo en el
diccionario está la palabra éxito antes
de trabajo que no hay verdades absolutas
mil rosas perfectas vivir y ser félix es
la única verdad ya por la vida está
hecha de momentos y en los detalles más
sencillos siento que van a la pena vivir
vale la pena
la pena
[Música]
a
sólo es
[Música]
la crisis